First, let’s make sure everybody here understands
what a calorie is.
A calorie is just a measurement of energy-
the amount of energy needed to raise 1 gram
of water 1 degree Celsius at standard atmospheric
pressure.
This makes sense when talking about calories
in food.
Food provides energy and our bodies need this
energy to function throughout the day.
I’m hoping to burn about 100 calories while
writing this response.
If not, this 100 calorie snack pack won’t
be as health conscious as I thought and will
go straight to my hips!
Second, it’s also important to note that
Calories in food are actually measured in
kilocalories, so 1000 actual calories for
every 1 Calorie listed.
Manufacturers used to measure calories using
a “bomb calorimeter”.
This process involved placing the food source
in a sealed container filled with water.
They would then burn the food with electrical
energy.
After the food had completely burned up, they
would measure the water temperature to see
how many degrees it was raised and thus how
many calories used.
In 1990, under The Nutrition Labeling and
Education Act of 1990, the FDA began requiring
food manufacturers to label the amounts of
nutrients and calories contained in their
products.
This act resulted in moving away from the
bomb calorimeter method for determining the
number of calories in food.
One reason for this was to make it easier
and less expensive for manufacturers to meet
the standard.
Another was that the bomb calorimeter method
measures all available calories in the product.
Since most foods contain indigestible components,
like fiber, that pass through our system and
get excreted in the form of bum brownies,
this would lead to a consistent overestimation
of ingested calories using the bomb calorimeter.
Instead, they used an easier method known
as the Atwater system.
This approach adds up the calories available
through the energy containing nutrients in
the food item, like protein, carbohydrates,
fats, and alcohols.
They use standard reference tables for common
ingredients based on their energy densities.
Things like 4 kilocalories for proteins, 4
for carbohydrates, 3 for organic acids, 9
for fats, and 7 for drinkable alcohols (ethanol).
No wonder all that beer gives me this soft
belly!
It has over 1.5 the calories per mass as proteins
and carbohydrates (well worth it though).
So for a specific example, let’s say that
tasty snack you have before you jump on the
treadmill contains 5g of protein, 10g of carbohydrates,
and 15g of fat.
The label on the package would then read 225
Calories (or 225,000 calories for those who
can’t stand over simplification which results
in misconceptions!)